while we are going to be casting votes
on an issue of enormous consequence and
that is whether we reappoint ben
bernanke as chairman of the fed and i'm
here to argue that that would be a very
bad decision that we should reject this
nomination that we need in this country
a new wall street which understands that
its function is not simply to make as
much money as it can for extraordinarily
wealthy people on the street but to
begin to integrate the functions of Wall
Street into our productive economy may
credit available to small and
medium-sized businesses so we can break
out of this horrendous recession which
is causing so much pain from one end of
this country to the other and in order
to create a new wall street we need a
new fake and we need a new Fed Chairman
who is going to provide new leadership
the same old same old is not going to
work madam president everybody in
America agrees and understands that a
little over a year ago our nation in
fact the world's financial system came
to the edge of a major collapse a major
collapse and Madam President everybody
also understands that the function of
the Fed is to protect the safety and
soundness of our financial institutions
that is its main function can anybody
deny with a straight face that the Fed
and its chairman mr. Bernanke failed at
its task they failed this is not a
personal attack against mr. Branca but
while Wall Street became
converted into the largest gambling
casino in the history of the world where
was mr. Bernanke and the Fed whose job
is to protect the safety and soundness
of our financial institutions they
weren't there and it seems to me to be a
very bad idea to reward somebody with
reappointment who failed at a enormously
important task which has driven this
country into a severe recession so that
seventeen percent of our workforce today
is either unemployed or underemployed
millions of our fellow Americans have
lost their homes they've lost their
savings they've lost their ability to
send their kids to college they've lost
their hopes for the future mr. Bernanke
failed at his job he should not be
rewarded with reappointment further
Madam President many of us after eight
years of the Bush administration we said
it is time for a change it is time to
change the priorities of this nation
time to move us in a new direction the
evidence is overwhelming that from an
economic perspective as well as many
other perspectives the Bush
administration failed let me quote from
the Washington Post earlier this month
and this is what they said about the
bush economy quote the past decade was
the worst for the US economy in modern
times it was according to a wide range
of data a lost decade let me repeat a
lost decade for American workers they
had has been zero net job creation since
December nineteen ninety 90
middle-income households made less in
2008 when adjusted for inflation than
they did in 1999 and the
about a lost decade standard of living
for American workers down creation of
wealth down for American workers Ben
Bernanke was not only appointed by
George W Bush to be chairman of the fed
Madam President he was a member of the
Bush administration in fact he was the
chairman a president bush's Council of
Economic Advisers why do you want to
reappoint somebody who not only failed
that his job is chairman of the Fed in
terms of protecting the safety and
soundness of our financial institutions
but was an architect of the bush economy
which was a disaster for American
workers Madam President we need a new
direction at the Fed and it's not only
looking back at the failures of mr.
Bernanke it is looking forward in saying
how can the Fed respond to begin to
protect the middle class and working
families of our country and here's
something that has not been discussed
enough the Fed today has enormous powers
now many will remember that is part of
the bailout mr. Bernanke and the Bush
administration not only pushed for a 700
billion dollar bailout for Wall Street
but on top of that mr. Bernanke provided
trillions of dollars let me underline
that trillions of dollars in zero
interest loans the large financial
institutions as a member of the Budget
Committee I had the opportunity to ask
mr. Bernanke which financial
institutions received those trillions of
dollars I don't think that's an
unreasonable question on behalf of the
American people and mr. Bernanke said in
so many words
sorry senator not going to tell you
American people don't have to know who
receive trillions of dollars of their
money back to me is totally unacceptable
we need transparency at the Fed and mr.
Bernanke has not provided that
transparency I have introduced
legislation to bring that transparency
to the Fed somebody whose views are very
different than mine on many issues Ron
Paul in the house brought similar
legislation we need transparency we need
a chairman of the Fed who will give us
that transparency and that's something
that mr. Bernanke can do tomorrow Madam
President in my state of Vermont that
I'm sure in your state of New York
people are calling you every single day
and they are saying we are sick and
tired of paying twenty five or thirty
percent interest rates on our credit
cards from the same banks and bunch of
crooks that we bailed out who got us
into this recession in the first place
now imagine that you have people who act
on Wall Street in a reckless
irresponsible illegal way taxpayers bail
them out and they say thank you
taxpayers by the way we're going to
raise your interest rates on your credit
cards have a nice day all over America
people cannot believe their outrage that
this is happening well you know what mr.
Bernanke and the Fed have the authority
today to lower interest rates on credit
cards they could do that today and that
is what they should do because one of
their responsibilities is to protect
consumers against outrageous and
fraudulent activities and in my view
charging people twenty five or thirty
percent is outrageous and fraudulent and
you zarus Madam President all over this
country the president mentioned it last
night appropriately so all over this
country small and medium-sized
businesses will make it a profit
are crying out for low-interest loans in
order to expand their businesses and to
hire new workers one of the great
economic problems we're having as a
nation president touched on at last
night is the need for small productive
businesses to get the low-interest loans
they need well mr. Bernanke was there
with zero interest loans for large
failed fraudulently dishonestly run Wall
Street firms but he ain't there for
small businesses all over this country
who desperately need low interest loans
the Fed has the authority today not
tomorrow today to provide low interest
loans to small and medium-sized
businesses so that we can begin to hire
new workers and bring our economy out of
the severe recession that we are
currently in Madam President the reason
as I understand it that the taxpayers of
this country against my vote I should
say were asked to bail out the crooks on
Wall Street was because they were too
big to fail you see if a small business
goes under that's okay somebody's worked
as whole life building the business
fails no problem we don't help them but
if you're a big large financial
institution and you engage in reckless
illegal behavior we bail you out because
if you go down you're going to take a
large part of the economy with you
you're too big to fail well many of my
colleagues might be surprised to know
that three out of the four largest
financial institutions in this country
that we bailed out because they were too
big to fail a bigger today than they
were before we bailed them out because
they were too big to fail now that may
make sense to somebody not to this
United States Senator it seems to me
that what common sense suggests is that
we break up these large financial
institutions so a that the American
people are never again put
in the position of having to bail them
out because they too big to fail and
second of all that we begin to
understand what Teddy Roosevelt
understood 100 years ago is that that
concentration of ownership is dangerous
for the economy today you have four
major banks who are writing who are
providing two-thirds of the credit cards
in this country for major financial
institutions two-thirds of all the
credit cards you have four major
financial institutions are writing half
the mortgages in America that's wrong
break up the large financial
institutions that we talked about all
over the world Ben Bernanke has the
ability to begin to do that tomorrow I
have not heard one word from him to
suggest that he will do that Madam
President the American people are angry
the American people are frustrated and
what they are angry and frustrated about
is that in many instances they are
working longer hours for lower wages
than they used to if they are fortunate
enough to have a job the American people
are frustrated and angry because this
immediate financial crisis and severe
recession was caused by the recklessness
and irresponsibility of a handful of
people on Wall Street and the American
people are frustrated and angry because
they are not seeing the kind of
accountability and change in terms of
the activities on Wall Street that they
expect and demand to happen quite the
contrary after having bailed out people
who acted in an illegal and
irresponsible way what they are seeing
is Wall Street puffin millions of
dollars into campaign
tributions and lobbying so that we can
bring them back to where they were
before the bailout the American people
want change in the way our financial
institutions run the American people
want change at the Fed and I believe the
American people want a new chairman or
chairwoman at the Fed now is the time to
say to the American people we hear you
we are going to bring about change we
are going to deny the reappointment of
Ben Bernanke chairman we are going to
ask President Bush to give us a new
nominee who's going to stand up for the
middle class and working class of this
country rather than for the big money
interests on Wall Street thank you very
much madam chair and with that I would
yield